Downie to pay for a demo Rio here and
one of the things that people don't
realize that a con like FGM excuse me
the Expo this one is that it is actually
very annoying when people go up to voice
actors who appear in a lot of cons and
request them to do certain voices or
certain songs or whatever and the reason
for that is is because they get asked so
many times like for example let's say
one of the guests here rob paulsen let's
say someone asked him to sing yakko's
well now he's gotten this request
millions of times it gets tiring you
notice there's a little twitch every
time somebody asks it but that is why
it's gonna be so unique when I ask it
and he does it for me because obviously
you know rob has seen Sam well how can
anyone not I haven't checked his website
but I'm sure we're on there so I'm gonna
go up I'm gonna ask him for you to sing
yakko's world the famous and a maniac
song and I think we're gonna get good
response out of him you see how this
goes
Rob Paulsen Rob Paulsen hi Donny Dubray
with a demo I just wants a big fan love
your work you're just you are my
childhood man it just so wonderful cell
machining time to pray I've connected
earlier way with them oh really yeah
nice to meet you Matt I said I just want
to ask a question cuz you're such an
awesome guy I was wondering uh could you
sing yakko's world by any chance I am
canta mean yeah yeah yeah you know the
yeah I don't know about oh look at that
oh really the picture we got a runner
Wilson you will indulge my childish
Natasha you are not yet indulging the
indulge in my figure now please stop the
hell
where'd you go but you're gonna where
are you
that's why rob paulsen I will find you
yes you can't run from me I can smell
your talent I swear we're all Paulson
wherever you go where you are I will no
Katy were so I was not able to get uh
Rob Paulsen to do ya cold world huh but
you know uh you take the losses and you
take the wins I still plan on taking the
win because uh this isn't my room are we
gonna do this on we're gonna it's on
right puzzle oh yeah let's what song
Hank are out yeah you know the song wait
wait wait wait
if I do yeah close world you will leave
me alone right this is effectively a
felony yeah yeah come on come on come
come I okay okay in the mirror in the
mirrors fever all together right happy
family here we go okay you ready to sing
a song I'm ready to sing your song ready
yes okay are you rolling I want to learn
I am I'm always really you ready you
ready yes and go United States Canada
Mexico Panama Haiti Jamaica Peru no no
no public that you wanted to sing the
song you sing oh the song dude no no no
okay the one book that Louisiana
Indianapolis Indiana and Columbus of
look up a little bit
that's wackos America that's what Jess
Harnell sang it's the same composer
Randy Rogel but it's about the states
and the capitals I sing about the
countries of the world you mean you put
me through all this bullshit for your
for your stupid thing and you don't even
know a song you want from me whatever
just do Leonardo I'm Raphael
who are you